your doctor may recommend a
ctc or mia hemorrhoid to remove your
hemorrhoids if they do not respond to
more conservative treatment hemorrhoidal veins
are blood vessels
within the walls of the rectum and
anal canal hemorrhoids also
known as 'major branches'
occur when these  veins swell
and the tissue around them becomes inflamed a
swollen vein near the entrance to the
anal canal is called
an external hemorrhoid a swollen vein inside the
rectum is called an internal
hemorrhoid internal hemorrhoids are classified by how
advanced they are
primary internal hemorrhoids  degree are those
that always remain within the rectum
second degree internal hemorrhoids
expand out of the rectum
during defecation and then return
to the rectum automatically
third degree internal hemorrhoids
extend out of the rectum during
defecation and then must be pushed out
inside the rectum
internal hemorrhoids  4th degree
hemorrhoids always stay out of the rectum and cannot be pushed back in before a ctc or mia hemorrhoid you
may receive local or
general anesthesia if you receive general anesthesia you
will receive sleep medications
through an oxygen mask or
through an IV  will insert a
breathing tube through your mouth and into your windpipe
to help you breathe during the
operation your surgeon will begin by
using an
electrocautery or laser scalpel to make an
incision in the tissue surrounding the
hemorrhoid to expose the swollen vein
your surgeon may ligate  the swollen vein
to prevent it from bleeding when it is
removed your surgeon will remove the
swollen vein and swollen tissue your wound
may be left open or your surgeon may
sew it up finally your surgeon
will place medicated bandages over the
wound to help it heal and
protect it from infection
The procedure usually lasts
about an hour after your procedure.  o
your breathing tube will be removed
you will be ordered to eat a high-
fiber diet and drink plenty of fluids to
avoid constipation during your recovery
which usually lasts two weeks to
two months
o warm baths may be recommended
medications or laxatives that make you
feel more  comfortable in the days after
your procedure most people
can go home the day of the
procedure but some need to
stay in the hospital for 1 to 2 days
after they go home you should call
your doctor right away if you have a fever
excessive pain drainage from the  wound
redness or swelling